today we're rounding up the latest
casting announcements from the new Titan
series plus we're gearing up for a very
special Batman Davis Saturday so get
ready for d-day all-access
[Music]
hey guys I'm Jason Inman I'm Whitney
Ward you can't swing a giant mallet
around here without hitting all the
latest TV news you need to know Bruce
Wayne's hometown is getting a new masked
vigilante and an overdose of fear toxin
in the fourth season of Gotham Bruce
takes a huge step in his evolution as
The Dark Knight and finds new purpose
fighting crime in the city's darkest
corners while scarecrow returns as
Gotham's most terrifying villain don't
miss the season 4 premiere on its new
night this Thursday on Fox Warner
Brothers is releasing a live-action
Titan series on its streaming platform
next year and the cast in new is Brenton
Thwaites is taking on the role of team
leader as Dick Grayson and he's joined
by Tegan Croft as the powerful empath
Raven and on Ajoke as the alien princess
Starfire Plus Hawk and duck are reported
for duty played by Alan Ritchson and
Minka Kelly to keep up with all the
latest news about WP is streaming
service head over to DC fan updates calm
Batman day 2017 is going down on
Saturday and this year's event is being
hijacked by a very special guest Harley
Quinn is organizing a massive Batman day
take over for her 25th anniversary
including cosplay contests and plenty of
activities for kids plus you can grab
free copies of Batman Day special
edition comics starring the Dark Knight
Harley Quinn and DC superhero girls
check out DC comics dot-com / Batman day
to find the celebration in your area and
get ready for an epic DC Saturday the
origin stories of The Nightmare Batman
are taking off in Batman the Red Death
an alternate version of Bruce Wayne
hijacked the Flash's access to the Speed
Force and soon his new abilities catch
the eye of Barbados who's hell-bent on
destroying our world the evil Batman one
shots provide crucial backstory for the
big bat in Dark Knight's metal so grab
your copy of Batman the Red Death
starting today a peace treaty violation
puts earth and space on the verge of war
in the wild storm Angeles pikas super
suit is to blame so bringing our end
becomes iOS number one priority plus
grifter has to help a team member
execute a heart pound
escaped from an assassination attempt
the wild storm number seven comes with a
preview of Michael Kray solo spin-off
series so make sure you snag a copy for
yourself this week
Wonder Woman left that mascara to save
man's world
and now she's departing the silver
screen so she can strengthen your
blu-ray collection aside from being able
to watch the movie every time you need a
confidence boost
you can catch extended scenes bloopers
and tons of behind the scenes features
to take you inside the making of a
superhero classic make Wonder Woman a
permanent fixture in your home on
blu-ray and DVD today in gaming news
Black Manta is available to the masses
and injustice to dip your toes into the
dark side to explore the power of mantas
super suit and drown your opponents with
a sub aquatic super move seize control
of the seven seas and download the evil
ocean master for injustice to now meta
human rights our panel of the week
rights and panel of the week rights our
meta Human Rights once and for all
[Music]
that's the news for now but don't forget
that you can catch a new episode of DC
all-access every weekday to stay
up-to-date on all the latest DC goodness
we'll see you next time